hello this is bi and today i'm doing
wired auto complete interview
[Music]
i never do that i never search my name
in google
this vi bag yes i'm back once again
hello everyone i'm back
is bi nice am i nice to other people
well i hope so but
you should hear about this from other
people's point of view
who is b.i favorite artist
is it wrong for me to say myself there
are so many artists can i think of like
post malone and kanye west definitely
tyler and destiny who i collab with
recently but it's
a little difficult to
pick just one favorite
who is b.i signed to
yeah actually
i signed to myself i started 131 label
with iok
who is bi stylist his name is chong
hwang up and i really like to work with
him he takes my ideas and
like it takes to a whole new level i
love you
where to buy bi album you should follow
official 131 label on instagram you can
find more information there
where is bi from
well i'm from korea more specifically
chonan chennai is
nearby seoul i think it's under my soul
next one is
where is bi now
i'm here korea more specifically i'm in
seoul at the studio for shooting wire
interview
when is bi next album
not allowed to say
but i'm working on my next album like
something special things coming soon so
please be patient with me and
you won't regret
it when is bi birthday
1996 october 22nd
what does bi stand for it's shortened
form
of bei it means
be myself it's a little cringy but but i
like it
what does b.i eli la mean illila is
just like
like wording
for describing the like rolling waves at
the seashore but it's not a dictionary
vocab if you picture it
it would make more sense
what is bi doing now actually i'm
working on my next album already
look forward to it
what is bi zodiac sign my zodiac sign is
it's libra i don't know why but
i've known the english word libra since
i was little
what is bi blood type my blood type is
oh
what is bis
bad song like i think my best song is
eli left for me but other artists vessel
is i think
beatles in my life
that's my best song
how old is bi my international age is
24.
how to pronounce bi yeah well b is like
b and i is like this this is my eyes
yeah b i you know what i'm saying
how tall is bi i'm 175.5
centimeter tall but i'm not really sure
and fit
how many followers does bi have on
what is instagram instagram i think it's
like
3.5 million or 3.6 million
does bi speak english yes hey heidi's
are you guys watching i'm speaking
english
does bi
play any instruments
piano maybe just a little bit but i'm
not that good at it
does bi drive yes i do drive recently
i got driver's license my fans are
really interested to see me driving
i don't know why
does b.i write his songs yes
i wrote every track
on my lady's album
and
actually my upcoming albums too
this vi act i try on my music video but
i don't think that is act is just
expressing
my emotion
does vi work out
well
i don't lift but i exercise like some of
push-ups and pull-ups something like
that and
i love climbing
why did bi start singing i don't want to
categorize rapping and singing it's just
another way of expressing the message of
my music and
i'm interested in like a lot of
different style of music and
i really like to explore something new
stuff
yeah
yeah some of the questions was made me
surprised but it was fun i like it
thank you